[Musique]
au québec les agronomes qui conseille
les agriculteurs pour l'utilisation des
pesticides sont pour la plupart des
salariés de compagnies qui vendent les
pesticides selon une enquête réalisée
pour le compte de l'ordre des agronomes
80% des entreprises leur verse des
primes des bonis ou des commissions ce
qui pourrait les encourager en
recommandé plus que nécessaire cet
agronome qui travaillait pour une
compagnie de pesticides jusqu'à l'an
dernier témoigne et le problème c'est
certainement pour la compétence
l'expertisé grenoble ceci pose jade est
beau ce qui est problématique c'est la
station dans laquelle sont mikit
illégale si on appelle lodetti de rendre
deux sens par exemple on voyage dans le
sud tenu par nos fournisseurs leur code
de déontologie est pourtant clair un
agronome doit s'abstenir de recevoir
tout avantage ristournes ou commission
relatif à l'exercice de sa profession
le président de l'ordre des agronomes
avoue son impuissance
nous acteurs n'ont pas d'impact sur la
façon de mettre des sites de travail et
non pour émettre des directives aux
agronomes
mais la façon qui est une île et agit on
aura aucun contrôle à tour l'ordre a
mandaté un comité d'experts pour lui
recommander des correctifs à apporter au
code de déontologie
c'est surtout notre peuple je fais le
voeu sincère que l'ordre diligente dans
les suites qu'elle vont donner vos
conclusions le délai du rapport qu'il a
rédigé il ya définitivement des conflits
d'intérêts au niveau de la neutralité
que les agriculteurs reçoivent comme
information il ya vraiment un momentum
intéressant en ce moment au niveau de
l'agriculture les gens veulent savoir de
plus en plus ce qu'ils mangent
est ce que oui il ya des pressions pour
vendre trop de produits chimiques aux
agriculteurs c'est ce qu'on veut savoir
l'industrie des pesticides assure que
ses agronomes sont des professionnels
qui offrent des conseils fiables et
qu'ils respectent la déontologie avec ou
sans risque
la commission parlementaire qui se
penchera sur l'impact des pesticides sur
la santé et l'environnement ne traitera
pas directement des questions
d'indépendance de la recherche en
agriculture ou des agronomes
les partis d'opposition ont essayé
d'ajouter ce mandat mais les députés de
la coalition avenir québec ont refusé
ici thomas gerber radio canada montréal